les balades bonjour merci d'avoir
accepté notre invitation ce matin en
direct sur rt france on disait 124
généraux à la retraite qui publie une
lettre où il dénonce notamment une
élection volée que dise précisément sur
le sujet ces généraux en fait il dit pas
grand chose ils disent que l'élection a
été volé mais il ne préconise pas de
d'autres traitements que de faire très
attention aux prochaines élections à ce
qu'il n'y ait pas de fraudes et que
c'est la plus grave crise
constitutionnelle qu'il y ait eu depuis
1776 depuis l'indépendance et que les
dangers présents actuellement sur la
chine l'iran et les frontières la
frontière sud du pays et que le
président by john n'est pas à la hauteur
de la situation
en plus ils ont des doutes sur sa
capacité à gouverner sa capacité
physique et mentale la fois à gouverner
mais il ne propose pas autre chose que
de faire de se rassembler pour les
prochaines élections législatives qui
vont avoir leur 2022 pour essayer de
rectifier le tir essayer de rectifier le
résultat qui a été tour selon eux volet
qui n'est pas le résultat que leur est
dû
[Musique]
alors qu'ils sont qui sont ces généraux
est ce qu'il y à des figures connues
parmi les signataires le seul enfin
celui qui structurent et et le clic et
serait le plus connu est en lice admiral
c'est l'amiral point texte mais il n'est
pas de première jeunesse il était le
conseiller en sécurité nationale de vice
conseiller en sécurité nationale du
président reagan donc ça ne manque pas
ça remonte à un bout de quarante ans
l'autre est un sénateur qui est un
général qui s'appelle bolduc et qui se
présente aux élections sénatoriales de
new hampshire et peut-être que ça va
jouer un petit rôle pour le faire
connaître un peu plus par les électeurs
et sur le plan national et il n'y a pas
de janeiro particulièrement connue c'est
un petit peu je vais pas dire que c'est
un an et 25 me dire mon dieu c'est pas
un événement sans importance mais c'est
ça je dois pas avoir énormément d'impact
d'abord toutes les chaînes de télévision
tout ce qui touche tous les médias
classiques ont fait l'impasse sur sa
entend très peu il ya le racing post 2
il ya où il ya ou news qui en parlent
mais ça n'est pas quelque chose je pense
que 95% des américains sont ne sont pas
au courant de cette lettre et cette
lettre contrairement à celle des
généraux français ne préconise pas née
d'une action immédiate la seule action
que qu'elle préconise ces deux de se
réunir pour la pour les prochaines
élections législatives et d'essayer de
reprendre le progrès aux démocrates
quel est le lien aux états unis entre
les militaires et les politiques est ce
que il y en imagine un devoir de réserve
aussi comme comme en france de la part
de ses généraux même à la retraite ont
pas à la retraite ils n'ont pas
véritablement de devoir de réserve
ils peuvent eux je te souvent ils sont
conseillés les conseillers d'anglais
dans des chaînes de télévision et disent
des choses que je n'aurais pas pu dire
s'il était encore en service actif mais
le
les généraux à la retraite peuvent
donner leur opinion sur tous les sujets
politiques sans que cela ne pose
problème au sein de l'armée beaucoup
soutiennent donald trump beaucoup oui
beaucoup de beaucoup de militaires
soutiennent donald trump
mais il le faut discrètement parce que
eux ont un débord le devoir de réserve
alors les généraux la ses 124 généraux
dénonce aussi le fait que depuis
l'intronisation de joe biden il y a des
dizaines de milliers de soldats qui
protègent la maison blanche comme si
elle allait être attaqué ça paraît quand
même un petit peu bizarre ce n'est
jamais arrivé dans toute l'histoire des
états unis
et il dénonce ça à juste titre
d'ailleurs
on va vraiment pas d'intérêt d'avoir
autant de soldats mobilisés et que là et
que la maison blanche soit devenue une
forteresse comme si elle allait être
prise d'assaut du jour au lendemain
alors que les événements que s'était
produit le 6 janvier étaient des
événements qu'on a voulu exagéré bien
enfin c'était quoi que quelques
centaines de personnes sans arbres qui
sont allés faire les pitres et souvent
des gens qui n'étaient même pas
politiser bon donc je vois pas en quoi
cela justifie d'avoir autant de soldats
qui protègent washington comme si
washington allait être occupé donc on va
attaquer par qui que ce soit alors il
parle de sa sas et quelques jeux c'est
un sujet qui évoque à juste titre alors
vous le rappelions on pense bien
évidemment à la tribune des nro français
en france qui elle a fait beaucoup de
bruit contrairement aux états unis comme
vous venez de nous dire cette tribune
des généraux français on en a parlé ou
pas aux états unis on a en a parlé oui
par les gelées les chaînes de
traditionnels en ont parlé enfin les
médias traditionnels ont parlé bon ils
ne sont pas trop rentrer dans les
détails mais je pense que l'impact de la
tribune des généraux à la retraite des
officiels de retraite en france et même
celle de deux militaires d'actifs a et
ce sera bien bien plus importantes que
l'impact de ces 124 officiers qui est
qu'ils n'ont pas véritablement de public
et qui est comme l'information est très
peu reprises parlé
traditionnels et les plus reprises par
les médias de ce conte en avant une
pause ou ou de vivre yahoo ont fait
vraiment pas papa pas le premier rang
des médias il ya peu de chances pour que
cela ait un impact national
et finalement c'est quoi mais comment
est ce que vous comprenez que que cette
lettre ouverte de ses 124 généraux et
bien elle soit pas elle soit pas relayé
aux états unis par les grands médias
parce que aux états unis on est rentré
dans une sorte de censure de tout ce qui
ne plaît pas tout ce qui n'est pas
politiquement correct tout ce qui
pourrait être positif par rapport à
train pour qui pourrait remettre en
cause la légitimité de byden donc en
deuxième censure qui s'exerce aussi bien
dans les médias traditionnels que dans
les réseaux sociaux qui a qui dépasse
tout ce qu on a pu voir jusqu'à présent
aux états unis peut-être qu'elle eut ce
genre ce type de censure pendant la
deuxième guerre mondiale
mais là on est à un stade de censure aux
états unis qui est inégalée jusqu'à
présent je n'ai jamais vu cette censure
donc les journaux les médias le fonds
des dab de la sélection d'informations
font l'impasse sur certaines
informations transforment certaines
informations et mais ne donne pas
véritablement le le tout de ce qui se
passe dans le pays
donc elles perdent beaucoup de
crédibilité d'ailleurs il ya de moins en
moins de personnes qui regardent les
médias traditionnels pour s'informer
merci beaucoup et bert à la ddt d'avoir
répondu à deux questions je le rappelle
vous êtes un soutien de donald trump et
vous étiez en direct depuis los angeles